people say you know Sugar's gotten Dana
White Privilege or UFC privilege this
happens in every sport it's not a sugar
thing it shouldn't be called Dana White
Privilege it should just be called the
star privilege it happens in all sports
so with Suga it's not that he had an
easy run and the UFC especially it's
very black and white when it comes to
mixed martial arts The Dana can only
control so much you have to perform they
can't make you win fights you know
especially if you're starching people
like uh he's done you know with the
Peter Yan fight that's a tough fight for
Sugar Sugar doesn't win that we're not
even taught having this conversation so
they can only quote unquote as they say
online protect him so much until he has
to you know do the work